لطالما ردد قضه الحرب الاسرائيليون ان
الهدف من العمليه العسكريه في قطاع غزه هو
القضاء على حركه حماس واستعاده الرهائن
ولم يتطرق اي منهم الى اعاده الاستيطان في
غزه الا ان بعض الاصوات من داخل اسرائيل
تصرح علنيه بتطلعات بعضهم لاعاده
الاستيطان في غزه وهذا الاعلام نشرته شركه
تطوير عقار تدعى هاري زهاف يعرض مخططات
لبناء فيلل مرسومه على خلفيه مبان مدمره
في غزه بعنوان المنزل على الشاطئ ليس حلما
كتبت الشركه ايضا في المنشور نحن في شركه
هاري زهاب نعمل على اعداد الاساس للعوده
الى جووش قطيف وقالت ان موظفيها بداوا
باستصلاح الاراضي وازاله القمامه وطرد
المتسللين على حد تعبيرها كما تحدثت
الشركه في منشورها عن نيتهم بناء مستوطنات
غش قطيف التي فكت كتها اسرائيل قبل
انسحابها من غزه عام
2005 في منشور اخر لنفس الشركه اعلنت عن
اسماء لمستوطنات مستقبليه مثل معالي اتز
مونا نفي قطيف وهي مستوطنات سابقه في قطاع
غزه لكن الرئيس التنفيذي للشركه زئيف
ابشتاين نفى لصحيفه ارتس نيه الشركه
الاستيطان في غزه وقال الاعلان مجرد مزاح
نحن لا نبني وليس لدينا نيه للبناء على
الرغم من اننا نود ذلك لكن القرار يتخذ من
قبل الحكومه وليس لدينا تاثير عليه اذا
المنشور اثار غضب الكثيرين على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي دعونا نتابع بعض
التفاعلات وهنا نبدا بحساب علي اذا علي
يقول يحاولون يغرونهم في البقاء بعد ما
المطارات امتلت بالمغادره مو اصحاب ارض
وخايفين وجيشهم غارق في غزه نصل ايضا الى
ليا احمد تقول احلامهم كثير كبيره ما شاء
الله اذا على غلاف غزه مو ادران يرجعوا عم
يحلموا على البحر كمان خليهم يشوفوا
جنودهم شو عم يصير فيهم وصلنا الى رنا
تقول رنا هنا حين يبداون باستفزاز
الفلسطينيين والحديث عن استيطان غزه
اعلموا انهم فشلوا في تحقيق اهدافهم على
الارض فيعيشون الفانتازيا واخيرا نصل معكم
الى رامي رامي يقول طالما حلموا باعاده
استيطان غزه مثلما يحدث في الضفه الغربيه
خطتهم عباره عن حلم صعب المنال و شهيتهم
مفتوحه للاستيطان على كل حال هذه ليست
المره الاولى التي تتعالى فيها اصوات
اسرائيليه تعبر عن رغبتهم في استيطان غزه
وفي الشهر الماضي انتشر العديد من الصور
للجنود الاسرائيليين يرفعون لافتات مكتوبا
عليها غوش قطيف عدنا